it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning and it is yet another big day
for Rishi sunak who'll be facing
kierstormer in his first prime
minister's questions at noon Mr sunac
has promised to fix the mistakes made by
his predecessor and started by clearing
out half of our cabinet in just a couple
of moments I'll be speaking to one of
the survivors the foreign secretary
James cleverley it is Wednesday the 26th
of October
I'm on Downing Street where the new
cabinet is about to meet for the first
time with experienced ministers like
Dominic Robb and Michael Gove back in
the fold
just seven women are included in surat's
top team including swella Braverman we
appointed his Home Secretary six days
after she was sacked for breaking the
ministerial Court
plus Rishi sunak gets an invitation to
visit Keith from president zielinski one
of the prime minister's first calls
after entering number 10.
I'm here in North London at the
country's biggest Hindu temple to hear
what it means to the community about
having the first of British Asian prime
minister
also a hands peers question whether
princes Andrew and Harry should be
allowed to stand in for the King on
official duties
no tolerance of hate speech Adidas Cuts
its ties with the rapper Kanye West
after a slew of anti-Semitic comments
natural Worlds at its spectacular
taking a bite out of the Sun the best
eclipse pictures from around the world
[Music]
and hitting the right note world
champion Tyson Fury hopes that Sweet
Caroline will become the England World
Cup anthem
[Music]
morning all Rishi sunak will be cheating
his first cabinet this morning before
going on to face kirstarma in the
Commons and prime minister's questions
the new pm has promised to prioritize
economic stability and confidence but
warrants this does mean difficult
decisions to come let's head straight to
our political correspondent Ali
Fortescue who's braving down in street
fighters this morning good to see you
Ali yeah it's a busy day
yeah morning morning a busy day 9 30
that is when um the new prime minister
Rishi sunak is going to meet his cabinet
for the very first time all together
we're expecting them to come in shortly
and as I was saying there are some
familiar faces from the past people like
Dominic Robb people like Michael go this
is a prime minister who I think in part
wants continuity some of the people that
are coming in are those already are
familiar with the brief for example
Dominic Robb who's going back to Justice
Steve Barkley who's going back to health
but also I think a prime minister that
wants to show he's reaching out to
different parts of the party including
for that for example swella braveman who
is back as Home Secretary now that has
been quite controversial I think this is
something that labor have been
sharpening their attack lines on
overnight they say that this is someone
who just a week ago broke the
ministerial code had to be sacked by Liz
truss for sharing information on a
private phone that is something that I'm
sure will come up potentially at Prime
Minister's questions that will be a big
moment for Rishi sunak the first time he
goes head to head against Kirsten that's
happening at noon these are two people
who are known to have their eye on the
details so it could be a very different
kind of prime minister's questions as
Rishi sunak heads into his first proper
day in the job
thanks indeed
uh now of course one of the people to
keep his cabinet job yesterday was the
foreign secretary James Cleveland very
pleased to see he joins us now and well
congratulations
I have to ask
happens when you go in I'm just
personally interested in this what
happens when you pop in to see the Prime
Minister I mean presumably the heart is
pounding as you walk up Downing Street
but what did he say well uh by
convention the conversations we have
tried in the cabinet room private but
I've known Rishi for a long while he
commented on the work that we've been
doing at the foreign office and it is a
proper team effort at the foreign office
I'm the person that sits on the on the
sofa but there's a big team there and
we've got a lot of work on he wanted
continuity uh and of course I'm
absolutely delighted to uh to stay in
the role and to serve under him as prime
minister now they're given of course the
fact that you have been remaining enroll
up I have no compunction but asking you
a couple of questions on the brief and
Peter tatchel of course a gay rights
campaign of many many years reputation
stopped in Qatar what is your
understanding of what actually took
place there because he claims a PSP
claimed that he was arrested the Qatari
authorities say something slightly
different well I'm going to get the
detail I'm going to be a bit careful
about the comments I make on that until
I get the full detail we have been
working very closely with the Qatari or
government and the authorities around
the football they are very very keen to
make sure that fans who are going there
to enjoy the football do so and stay
safe I will look into detail of what
happened with Peter tatchell obviously
he wanted to make a point about gay
rights these are incredibly important
points and issues I have raised with the
qataris directly but I want to get the
full details before I comment further
just in terms of of the way in which
you've raised these particular issues
with the Qatari authorities I mean how
do you feel it is best the way how the
West is best placed to try and affect
some some changes in a part of the world
that we are very very close to well we
have incredibly important Partners in
the Middle East that used to be the part
of the world that I uh worked with when
I was the minister previously in the
foreign office and look these are these
are Muslim countries they have a very
different cultural starting point for us
I think it's important when you're a
visitor to a country that you respect
the culture of your host nation we do
talk to them about our values and why we
believe it's important that people's
rights from all kinds of communities are
respected and of course it will be
something that we continue to talk to
them about but ultimately they are very
very keen to make sure that football
fans have a an enjoyable experience and
they have made a number of compromises
to facilitate that and let's of course
talk now about the events of the past 24
48 hours
before entering Downing Street yesterday
a pledge to govern with Integrity
professionalism and accountability how
can you square that with the
reappointment of swella Braverman well
suela made a mistake she has said
herself that she made a mistake she's
apologized for that mistake and she
stood down at the time but ultimately
she has uh I think got very very clear
ideas about how we improve the
performance of the home office both in
terms of border control policing how we
make sure we crack down on crime she's
very passionate about that got a very
clear agenda for that and obviously that
the Prime Minister wanted to see that
delivered this was no minor mistake she
was sacked on the advice of the cabinet
secretary after not just shading from
her personal email but for pre-releasing
details of a ministerial statement so
I'll ask her to get when Rishi sunak
talks about displaying Integrity
professionalism and accountability in
government
you're not telling me that she's the
best person for the job given she was
sacked for not being very good at it a
handful of days ago well she has said
that she she made an error she has
apologized for that and the Prime
Minister has clearly taken the apology
at uh you know in in the manner that she
wanted to put across she has shown a
willingness to take responsibility for
what happened but ultimately he has
decided that he wants to see the agenda
that she has set out that very important
crime fighting agenda back in the heart
of government she is back in cabinet
isn't she because she provided her
endorsement for Rishi sunak ahead of him
becoming prime minister that's the
simple truth of this well if you look at
the Parliamentary numbers if you look at
the Parliamentary numbers it was clear
and clear really very very early on that
Rishi was going to have uh the majority
and as it went on to uh to be clear the
overwhelming majority of the support of
the Parliamentary party Frank I don't
think he needed the endorsement of
anyone at MP that is yeah well it's the
way to look at it because the numbers
speak for themselves
she gets sacked for a significant
security breach she meets with Rishi
sunak she provides her endorsement for
Rishi sunak she finds herself back in
cabinet in six days genuinely
people will be watching this screaming
at the television at the idea that their
intelligence is being insulted by the
fact that she was returned to cabinet on
the basis of her strengths rather than
on the basis of the endorsement I mean
even if it didn't take place that's what
it looks like well look I can't I can't
control I can't control people's
perception events but I can see what I
saw is that Rishi didn't basically need
any uh endorsements and and actually
look my appointment shows my appointment
showed I you know I supported someone
else now I know Rishi is an incredibly
smart politician who has incredibly
experienced Chancellor and has got a
very clear understanding of what we need
to do to get the British economy in the
place where we want it to be now but I
endorse someone else nevertheless
nevertheless
he asked me to stay in my position the
simple truth matter is he didn't need
any particular endorsements because it
was so clear that the Parliamentary
party wanted him at the at the helm
there will be people however then if
even if they take that at face value if
you question the Integrity the property
of a new prime minister who returns
someone to one of the great offices of
State let's not forget you know a
handful of days after she was sacked
from it I mean is there that much of a
lack of talent in conservative ranks
these days that Sue Ella bravaman is
truly the only person who can do the job
well look that's what it looks like well
you want to be you want to be critical
of us uh uh politicians and of course
that is that is an important part of the
other function of uh scrutiny but the
simple the simple fact of the matter is
well has a very very clear idea and set
out a very clear agenda about getting
control of our borders which is
incredibly important cracking down on
crime which is incredibly important she
made an error she uh uh apologized for
that and it's clear that uh the the
commitment that she's made to crack down
on crime is an important one for all of
us and that's why the Prime Minister
appointed does this mean that Russia
will be appointing an Ethics advisor I
mean presumably not
well the I mean the ultimately the an
Ethics advisor people keep using this as
if it's some kind of uh um you know
foundation stone of government it's
suspect that they have something to say
about the reappointment of suela
bravaman well the uh the point is we
have uh assistant cabinet secretary
there is a whole system in terms of
propriety and ethics uh within uh
government having one additional person
in in what is already a a
multi-individual function I'm not
convinced is uh is the is the golden
bullet uh that or the Silver Bullet
rather that some people's Justice
um let's talk about the the biggest
pressing issues facing the country at
the moment cost of living crisis we had
been led to believe that we would be
getting a statement from the chancellor
on Halloween reports this morning that
that it could be delayed what's your
understanding of where we are well I
haven't had a specific confirmation of
dates but obviously uh just yesterday we
had a new prime minister he's going
through the uh appointment of his
government he of course will want to
take some time to work on the detail of
that he's been Chancellor he will of
course have a very uh good understanding
of the figures he'll be working closely
with Jeremy in terms of the production
of that so it's like you're suggesting
it might look but we know it needs to
come soon we know people want certainty
we know people want a clear idea of the
government's plans whether it happens
exactly on that day I'm not able to
confirm at the moment what is your
understanding then of the joint approach
The Joint sunak hunt approach and all of
this I mean listening listening to the
Prime Minister yesterday on outside
number 10. you know I'll admit to being
a little confused I mean this is what he
said he was talking about giving us a
stronger NHS better schools safer
streets controllable borders protecting
our environment supporting our Armed
Forces I mean all of that surely
requires real-time spending increases
which is the one thing we're not going
to be getting well so I I think it's
really important
improving our schools yeah so we this
good government cannot just be about
spending lots more money
um we have to make sure that those
Public Services the Public Services on
which we all rely AI work effectively
efficiently and are very very delivery
focused but we can't just keep giving a
you know above inflation uh spending
increases the maths the maths just
precludes that from happening so yes we
have to make sure that we keep a close
eye on public expenditure but also what
we've got to do is make sure we keep a
close eye on being very very delivery
focused they are not mutually exclusive
sure but when Jeremy Hunt talks about
making very very difficult decisions we
all know what that is called for and it
is cuts to public spending I mean we had
again from the Prime Minister yesterday
that he feels that there is a mandate
that flows from the 2019 manifest or an
election the one thing that anyone who
voted conservative back in 2019 did not
vote for was austerity well we've got to
remember that between the 2019 election
and now we have had uh the furlough
scheme we have spent billions hundreds
of billions of pounds keeping people's
families together economically keeping
people in their jobs making sure
businesses don't go under so we have had
a massive massive massive increase in
public spending already and we can't
just pretend that away those challenges
those challenges were then made worse by
the economic implications of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine so we but so we so
we can't just we can't just pretend that
expenditure has not happened we will
continue to support people people who we
know are struggling economically people
who we know are worried about the future
and we will of course support them but
we can't just pretend that that massive
amount of public expenditure hasn't
already happened
I I think I know the answer to this
question but it but it strikes me that
if you wanted to put forwards you know a
package of public spending cuts you know
one thing you need is a mandate given
that the Mandate was not provided by the
2019 Manifesto why shouldn't there be a
general election now barring the fact
that the conservative party going by the
polling would be wiped out because you
always have to make Dynamic decisions in
government you can't set out a a
Manifesto and assume that nothing uh
significant is going to happen over the
four five tax Rises there could be no
public spending so there will be so
there was no there was no there was no
there was no Global pandemic sure in the
2019 uh uh Manifesto there was no
invasion of Ukraine in the 2019
manufacturing we have got to respond to
the world as we find it not the one we
wish it to be and there have been two
huge Global events and they are
affecting they are affecting countries
right across the world I was on the
phone yesterday to my office numbers
across the globe and we are all facing
these difficulties and we all have to do
it but especially soon I admitted
yesterday before he entered number 10
mistakes were made and mistakes were
made by the conservative government
which exacerbated the financial
situation I do just want to conclude on
one thing though and you mentioned it on
passion earlier that you did support
someone else that you supported Boris
Johnson I have to ask you you must have
received some assurances that he was
going to stand when he announced that he
was not how did that make you feel I
mean hung Nadeem zahawi out to dry well
we we could see that the uh the support
that he was getting was uh around the
hundred mark that was enough for him to
stand his intention the conversations I
had with him his intention was to stand
well look I was I was disappointed he
didn't put himself forward but
ultimately it was becoming clear even on
uh the even on the you know uh uh the
the the Sunday Monday it was becoming
increasingly clear that the
Parliamentary party over overwhelmingly
wanted to see uh Rishi sunak at the helm
we absolutely respect that Rishi is as I
say an experienced thoughtful and
energetic politician I'm very very happy
to serve in his government James quickly
good to see you we'll let you crack on
on a busy day thanks very much
now let's have a quick look at the
papers and we start with the telegraph
uh Rishi Cena votes to fix the mistakes
made under Liz truss in his first dining
Street uh address that's in the
telegraph
other times two are making that pledge
it's front page lead story
at the guardian it calls the gamble a
sorry the reshuffle a Gamble and
restoring experienced hands to Canada
including swella Braven just days after
she was forced to resign for between the
ministerial Court
and here's the star it's like instant
cabinet reshuttle to the hokikoki as Mr
sunak put some in and put some out
shakes it all about
uh while the sun imagines the new prime
minister talking to Larry the dining
Street cat telling him at least I got
rid of the other mug reference of course
to Jacob Reese
now Rishi sunak is of course the UK's
first prime minister of Asian Heritage
and the first Hindu to hold the office
sky sabacho is at the UK's biggest Hindu
temple for us this morning Saba good to
see you that's what's been the reaction
Good Morning Neil well Rishi suno
becoming the first-handed Prime Minister
coincides with the celebration of the
valley it's celebrated by Hindus seeks
James it's a five-day celebration that
celebrates the Triumph of good over
eagle and it's why at the temple behind
the Kingswood Temple is rather busy at
the moment or this time in the morning
for almost 20 past seven there's a five
Day celebration now joining me is a
teacher who works at Kingsbury Temple
her name is Joshua Joshi thank you for
joining me on Sky News Now earlier I had
a look at the display that is behind us
and I saw a picture of Rishi sunang just
over there why is that there and what
does that mean to you well in the
display we also have our jaria
who is our inspirator and alongside him
we decided that we're going to put the
queen as we're celebrating Commonwealth
Nations as well because it's important
to have physical leaders to Showcase and
be inspirational and be role models for
the future generation and you're also a
teacher Saturday school teacher here at
the temple what does it mean for you as
a as an educator to your Indian students
is this something that you think that
they can Aspire towards what's the
general sentiment amongst the children
whether it's for hopeful of Greater
diversity or inclusion or whether you're
just being inspired about at such a
young age he's achieved so much I think
it's something for the future generation
for the children to know that they can
have their dreams dream big and go for
the Stars really and reach for the stars
because anyone can now be a prime
minister something for them to Aspire to
and we just wish to wish you soon acts
the best and hope that he can get some
positive outcomes for our country
brilliant well thank you so much for
speaking to us on Sky News uh joshu now
Mr sunac is it has been reported widely
he is a around Hindu like he just
yesterday when he was made King
officially sorry when he met King
Charles III yesterday and became prime
minister officially there were some
Diwali Suites that were almost like he's
often seen wearing a red bracelet which
is known as a narratory on his wrist and
also in 2020 outside number 11 when he
was chancellored the exchequer he lit
some uh lit some viewers outside his
home which are basically some oil lamps
and had decorated at number 11 down the
street too so Rishi Sue and act becoming
the first Hindu prime minister it means
a lot to the people here that I've
spoken to but more generally speaking
questions will of course be raised about
his level of support he was voted in by
MPS rather than the general public in a
general election and also another
question to consider is when it comes to
policies how much will his cultural
program
so thanks very much indeed no all eyes
will of course be on the House of
Commons a little later today when barely
24 hours into the job Rishi sunak will
be facing the labor leader secure
starmer in Mr sunx first prime
minister's questions we'll have live
coverage here on Sky News from midday
ah but still to come I will Rishi sunak
be limbering up for prime minister's
questions I'll be speaking to two former
special advisors who've been there and
done it
the NHS needs you at 7 45 we'll hear
about the volunteers helping their
Community this winter and how you can
join them
and later on the former world
heavyweight boxing champion Vitali
Klitschko tells us about the biggest
fight of his life defending his country
from Russian invasion
iballistics with Ukraine and one of
Rishi tunak's first calls as prime
minister was to the country's President
Vladimir zielinski who he promised the
UK's continued support in its war
against Russia and he received an early
invitation to visit Kiev
just before recording this address I
spoke with the new British prime
minister Rishi sunak I believe that the
partnership between our countries and
the already traditional British
leadership in the defense of democracy
and freedom will continue to strengthen
Ukraine and Britain have achieved the
best relations so far but there is still
potential to increase our cooperation to
bring more benefits to our societies I
invited the prime minister to visit
Ukraine
meanwhile the Secretary General of NATO
has told Sky News that reports of a
possible nuclear attack in Ukraine risk
what he called a very serious escalation
yeah and stoltenberg was speaking to our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes during a NATO exercise in the
Adriatic
strength counts when Russia's watching
this U.S aircraft carrier is operating
in European Waters in a deliberate show
of force
it's part of a NATO Mission that's come
into sharper Focus
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine
this is routine training for NATO but
should Rutgers war with Ukraine escalate
significantly Pilots like these could be
called upon to go into combat for real
paying the warship per visit the head of
the alliance said the goal is to deter
threats
he shared concerns about a false claim
by Russia that Ukraine is planning to
use a radioactive dirty bomb on its own
territory Russia has accused others for
things they intend to do themselves so
we need to monitor closely what Russia
now do and and and they must know that
use of a
dirty bomb border a radiological bomb is
is a serious escalation
with so much uncertainty the pilots
flying these f-18s face the possibility
of one day fighting with Russia in
air-to-air combat for real it's daunting
all we do out here is trained to get
ready for a fight that might come and uh
I mean I think when it becomes pilot to
Pilot I hope that we're The Better Man
in the Box
in the past few days U.S debts have
flown close to Russia while two Russian
warships have watched the carrier from a
distance
no one wants conflict but everyone's
aware of the risks you're always ready
to execute uh the full spectrum of
maritime operations so you'd be ready to
go to war if if the call came if we are
if we are directed certainly that's what
we prepared for but what we are also
here is for um is to bring peace and
stability because that's what we do
the hope is that showing NATO is ready
and able to fight means it won't have to
Deborah Haynes Sky News on board USS
George H.W bush
uh time for a quick look at some of the
day's other headlines now and Prince
Harry and Prince Andrew's Royal duties
have been discussed in Parliament for
the first time as Lords have questioned
whether the Dukes should be allowed to
perform official duties for the king
peers in the Lords are Stephanie and
Andrew should remain as counselors of
State at the labor peer at Vicente
raised the issue in the House of Lords
asking if the government planned to
amend the Regency Act
is the government happy to continue with
the situation where the a canceled as a
state and Regency Powers may be
exercised by the Duke of York or the
Duke of Sussex one of whom has left
public life and one of whom has left the
country
so is it not time my lords for the
government to approach the king and see
if a sensible amendment can be made to
this act
a woman says she froze after Harvey
Weinstein took her into a hotel bathroom
and raped her just hours after they'd
met she was a witness at the former film
producers trial in Los Angeles when he
faces 11 charges of rape and sexual
assault he is already serving a 23-year
sentence for sex offenses against women
a new report says that governments and
companies are continuing to prioritize
the use of fossil fuels despite the
severe damage to People's Health caused
by climate change they'll answer
countdown released ahead of cop 27 in
Egypt next week ones that countries
subsidized fossil fuels to the tune of
400 billion dollars in 2019.
welcome back a quick reminder as to our
top stories and Rishi sunak will
assemble his cabinet for the first time
this morning as he gets to work tackling
his Hefty entry
then all eyes shift to the House of
Commons as he faces liberally to secure
starmer a prime minister's questions for
the very first time
and in one of his first calls as prime
minister Rishi sunak received an
invitation to Kiev from president
zielinski
foreign
of course we've just seen the Prime
Minister putting together his cabinet
and one of the most controversial
appointments has to be Sue Ella
Braverman back his Home Secretary six
days after being sacked for breaking the
ministerial codes a little earlier I
spoke with the foreign secretary James
cleverley he told me she had apologized
and said the new PM trusted her vision
well she has said that she she made an
error she has apologized for that and
the Prime Minister has clearly taken the
apology at uh you know in in the manner
that she wanted to put across she has
shown a willingness to take
responsibility for what happened but
ultimately he has decided that he wants
to see the agenda that she has set out
that very important crime fighting
agenda back in the heart of government
suspicion that that story May well crop
out prime minister's questions today
premises questions today but of course
we also asked the foreign secretary
about the economic strategy that Mr
sunak will be developing and whether or
not that financial statement would be
going ahead on Halloween the 31st of
October as originally intended here's
what he said
well I haven't had a specific
confirmation of days but obviously uh
just yesterday we had a new prime
minister he's going through the uh
appointment of his government he of
course wants to take some time to work
on the detail of that he's been
Chancellor he will of course have a very
a good understanding of the figures
he'll be working closely with Jeremy in
terms of the production of that so it's
like you're suggesting it might look but
we know it needs to come soon we know
people want certainty we know people
want a clear idea of the government's
plans whether it happens exactly on that
day I'm not able to confirm at the
moment
foreign let's head back to Downing
Street where we'll discover Ali
Fortescue and Ali let's let's try and
talk about two things if we can at the
same time um first of course I think
that's Well abrahman's story will run
and run but of course the priority for
the man who lives in the building behind
you Rishi sunak is sorting out the
economy and there will be some who are
slightly concerned uh the the moving or
the potential that that 31st of October
financial statement might have to be
moved
yeah let's start on the economy the
times are reporting that that
statement's been moved of course
Halloween was the moment that we were
going to get a sense of how the
government planned to steady the economy
and the warning was that that could well
mean a spending squeeze warnings even
that we could see austerity Hawking back
to George Osborne times or even worse
after Liz truss's pretty disastrous
economic policies so that was that is
the warning but um at the moment the
treasury are not confirming and nor is
James cleverley it sounds like they are
trying to work out whether it can happen
on Monday he said we know it needs to
come soon but I'm not able to confirm if
it's going to come on Monday and he was
clean to point um to Global events he
said that we have to deal with things as
we find them so I think expect a
potentially painful statement if that
does happen on Monday I think the reason
it needs to happen on Monday is because
the bank of England on Thursday are
looking at interest rates which could be
raised further which could impact
mortgages you talked about about sweller
braveman very briefly I think that is
something that labor are going to be
focusing in on at Prime Minister's
questions this is a Home Secretary who a
week ago was sacked under Liz truss for
breaching the ministerial code for
sharing information on a personal phone
and they are saying this is someone
Rishi sunaki says he wants to be
different wants to show professionalism
is it right that she has been brought
back into the fold
Ali thanks very much indeed uh well
let's reflect then get Insider's view of
the cabinet reshuffle and look ahead to
prime minister's questions the first
outing always an interesting one for a
new prime minister uh Charles Wilkes is
a former economic advisor to Theresa May
in number 10 Catherine MacLeod I was an
advisor to Alistair darling when he was
Chancellor for labor lovely to see you
both um I'll come to you first however
let's start with the appointment of the
reappointment I should say of of Suella
Braverman what do you make of it I mean
we are being told and I was told at
Great length that this was nothing to do
with securing an endorsement from the
rights of the party and instead just
that Mr sunac truly truly believes in
her policies
I find that slightly difficult to
believe because we all know how tight
things were on over the weekend it was
only a few days ago that we weren't
absolutely clear that Boris Johnson was
going to pull out of the race and if he
had got into the race and made it to the
final two all the betting was that Boris
Johnson would be looking at becoming
prime minister within the next few days
so Sue Ella braverman's endorsement of
Richie sunac was arguably the most
important endorsement of the entire race
and so it's very hard to believe that
such an important political choice of
hers didn't have any um to say at all in
this rather controversial decision of
his so you know some people were saying
when she was originally
um sacked last week that it was a
technical breach it wasn't a
particularly important one it looked
like a pretty serious one to me in that
she was sharing information and in a
sense trying to attack her own
government's policy by sharing it with
people who didn't agree with it
but you know a new a new a new prime
minister he must think I can draw a
clean slate over everything there's not
going to be that people won't talk about
it for more than a few weeks I think
labor are going to use it for a great
deal longer than that
yeah I mean Catherine I mean if we
wanted an example of a prime minister
who thinks you know keep your enemy
you'll keep your friends close but your
enemies closer you know this cabinet is
one of them but but but is it
sustainable in the long term or do you
see as as others are suggesting this
morning that this is just the first
stage that we will be seeing a much
larger reshuffle perhaps in a couple of
months time
and it's very hard to see at this stage
how it's relatively women can survive
she's the minister responsible for
security and pleasing she's breached
these um the bridge security herself
James cleverley was on your program a
minute of closing she said sorry
um so that's okay then well you know
what is part of you know the criminals
of the land going to see when standing
up on court we're sorry it's okay the
home secretaries could off with it so we
can too it's a very odd appointment and
I think it demonstrates that he's doing
more to appease the conservative party
than he cares about the country because
he's going to get off to a very bad
start because she's a discredited
politician she's not the only one in his
cabinet Gavin Wilson Gavin Williamson
also breached the rules so for our for
our prime minister who say a great store
by integrity and accountability and
professionalism I think it's a mistake
um gels let's talk then about the kind
of the greatest item on on the new prime
minister's to-do list sorting out the
economy and and we did see the star we
did see staring strengthening against
the dollar just on the on the
announcement of his appointment to prime
minister I mean the markets are
certainly a bit calmer than they were
but we are still in this kind of interim
period where we haven't had the the 31st
of October financial statement looks
like it's not going to happen on that
date we haven't had the obr costing and
we're still trying to work out where 40
billion pounds is coming from yeah I
mean this the the challenge has only
just begun for the Prime Minister
because he not only needs to put in
place measures that calm the market so
the markets are now expecting them
they're not thinking game over it's all
fine we now have grown-ups in charge
they expect the grown-ups now to do
things raise some taxes take some
difficult decisions he needs to get
those through his party his party which
has recently been at its at its own
throat and that's that's not going to be
easy at all because there are different
views about whether taxes or spending
should be looked at first there are even
different views about how far you need
to go there will be people who still
think that it's not fair that Liz
truss's policy was taken out so quickly
and the most difficult one of all is he
needs somehow to separate himself from
the government that brought us to all of
this this catastrophe so a lot of the
people he's sitting around with on the
cabinet table would have been banging
that table cheering this the
quasi-quarting budget of just over a
month ago and now they've already got to
be going out into the on the airwaves
with solemn faces saying that you know
we're taking measures to deal with this
and somehow pretending they're not the
same kind of government with the same
kind of
um views so it's a really difficult
Balancing Act for him to do and I'm not
sure whether it's possible to please all
of those objectives at once
a Catherine a word from you about what I
think will be an absolutely fascinating
relationship to watch develop that
between the occupants of number 10 and
and number 11. once again and this goes
to your own personal experience we have
a prime minister who was Chancellor and
has a very very clear idea of the fiscal
Direction he wants to go and you have a
a Chancellor next door at trying to sort
out a massive crisis how does it work at
times like that when you've got a guy in
number 10 who thinks he can do the job
at number 11 bet on the guy who's in
there
well most of the time it works well
during the financial crisis Alistair
darling and Gordon Brown worked very
well together and the
contributed hugely to sort of a global
solution it did the relationship came
unstuck over the domestic policy towards
the end of the liberal government
however I think that there's not much
that we know about what Russia believes
in about the economy he was you know
it's unfair actually to put it all in
this trustless days he was sat in the
cabinet he was apparently the architect
of this January hunt actually was out of
government longer than sunocoas if from
what we we don't it's it's a very
interesting position that we've got a
prime minister now who has reached
number 10 without giving us his agenda
we don't know what he's about from what
I can see sitting here is that perhaps
there's not much ideological difference
between Jeremy Hunt and Lucy sonnet and
if that is the case
um they should get on fine the
difference between Alistair darling and
Gordon Brown was that Gordon Brown did
not think that
um Aleister should
it cut the domestic budget as quickly as
he wanted to do and in fact did
very good point very good point and
Charles just a quick word then about the
significance the import of pmqs today I
mean everyone no one expects this to be
Rishi sunak's best performance he's only
been in the job for five minutes but he
does need to come out swinging
yeah he absolutely must do I mean
they're going to want to be seeing
whether the support for him behind him
so whether they get a huge cheer when he
attacks labor back the the answer to the
swella bravaman question is going to be
intriguing you've got to remember that
kirstama had been beating Boris Johnson
handily on questions of integrity and
responsibility in the conduct of
government he's well practiced at this
he's he's he's extremely warmed up for
attacking a government that doesn't seem
to follow through on the values it's
meant to be promoting and he'll be
absolutely wanting to tear into Rishi
sunak so we've never seen sunak in such
a difficult situation he's normally had
the relatively supportive house
supporting his covid measures for
example have been his biggest moment so
we're going to see him in circumstances
we've never seen before and a lot of
Tory MPS will be very anxious because if
he can't stand up to it as things get
worse over the winter and the energy
bills rise and mortgage
um costs go up as well will he start
fraying a bit like the other Prime
Ministers having the past
and Catherine then just a very quick
word from you if we can because we're
just about out of time what about
starmer what does he need to do
well stamina needs to find out what Lucy
sunic is about he needs to establish
perhaps so she said Nick is too rich to
be the Prime Minister does he understand
what is the cost of living crisis that
people are experiencing in the country
when Marcus rashford sees children need
School dinners because they're starving
does Lucy understand that that is
actually the case if he can do that I
think the labor party will be cheating
too I think jazz is absolutely right of
course the Tories will be cheating when
Lucy's when Evolution stands up in the
comments but I don't think that they
might be hiding quite a few
uneasy back benches who will not be at
all happy that he's there I think what
he's going to see him
Kathy McLeod jonesworks lovely to see
you both thanks for joining us this
morning appreciate your time
now a bit of other news for you probably
picked up on this one Adidas uh well
they've said that they've stopped
working with the rapper Kanye West
because in their words they won't
tolerate anti-Semitism on any other type
of hate speech at this report from a U.S
correspondent Martha Kellner does
include some flash photography and also
comments which some people may find
offensive
Kanye West has built a career on being a
provocateur
but he has now found the limit of what
is acceptable and far beyond that a
barrage of anti-Semitic tirades in
recent weeks have made one of the music
industry's most successful artists a
pariah in his own Parish on a podcast
overnight he was peddling this tired old
Trope there's been times where I had my
lawyer was Jewish my regular was Jewish
but like like eight people that
basically would collude and talk without
me were in groups saying okay this is
what the tour is going to be this is his
next house and they were making all
these decisions and they're making all
this money West's hate speech comes amid
a rising anti-semitic incidents in
America this was a protest by Nazis in
Los Angeles over the weekend Kanye is
right one Banner says and Sky News has
obtained this video of a group under the
cover of Darkness Distributing
anti-semitic leaflets in an LA
neighborhood a few of them landed on Sam
and Leia yebrey's doorstep they spew
horrible anti-semitic conspiracy
theories about Jews being behind covid
or the lgbtq movement or controlling
president Trump do you feel like Kanye
West Has emboldened This Racist Hate
Story week he's a walking billboard for
for this hate I mean the billboard did
say Kanye's right so you have to connect
the dots imagine being someone who's
been trafficking and anti-Semitism for
years and now one of the biggest
celebrities in the entire world uh
validates your ideas uh this is this is
a boon for the haters and the bigots out
there
West has now been dropped by his
sponsors dismissed by social media
platforms and disavowed by celebrity
friends his ex-wife Kim Kardashian
writing hate speech is never okay or
excusable and calling for hateful
rhetoric against the Jewish Community to
come to an end
Adidas were under enormous pressure to
terminate their partnership with Kanye
West and they have now done so they say
it will cost them almost 250 million
dollars Financial experts predict it
will cost West over 1 billion dollars
in a statement Adidas said yay's recent
comments and actions have been
unacceptable hateful and dangerous and
they violate the company's values of
diversity and inclusion mutual respect
and fairness
Kanye West has decimated his reputation
and taken a sledgehammer to his fortune
even more damaging he's Amplified lies
which Jewish people have battled for
decades and from that his name may never
recover Martha Kellner Sky News Los
Angeles
people in parts of the UK have been
enjoying a partial solar eclipse a small
bite-sized chunk of the sun was obscured
by the moon as you can see approximately
a quarter of its area people found
various ways of looking at it safely
from using special eclipse glasses to
some rather more complicated telescopes
the eclipse was seen in several parts of
the world but I'm afraid to say there
won't be another one visible in the UK
until 2025.
welcome back the NHS needs you 26
million people are needing to receive a
booster jab this winter that means 7 000
shifts at vaccination centers across
England need filling every week it is a
big big old task about joining us now to
tell us how you can get involved the
Royal voluntary service director Fiona
Longhurst Fiona lovely to see you this
morning
um just give us an idea of of the scale
of the assistance that will be needed to
get this this booster program rolling
and we're talking about you know
everyone over the age of 50 getting a
Top-Up that's right I mean it's a huge
undertaking we've got 26 million people
needing to have their vaccination uh
over the coming months um this week they
hit the uh the 10 million Mark so it's
going well but we need everybody to come
forward and have their Jabs when they're
called and we need assistance to help
get the Jabs done and at Royal voluntary
service we're working with the NHS to
support that and we have our Steward
volunteers who are working with the NHS
alongside as part of the team and they
do a fantastic job they make people feel
at ease as they come in to have their
have their vaccination not everyone
loves that too they they these Steward
volunteers do a wonderful job they bring
people through the process make sure
things run smoothly assist the NHS team
working right alongside them uh and it's
a team role people really enjoy taking
part in this but it is a huge
undertaking and so far I think we've
done over 300 000 stewardships through
the whole vac destination program to
date but there's many many more shifts
to do I think we've got 30 000 in the
system up until Christmas so we do need
more hands on deck so so if people if
people want to to get involved and
helpful actually before we ask that so
it is just a steward rule if I apply to
kind of come in and join I'm not going
to be given a big needle and starting
you know starting putting booster shots
into people's arms no definitely not
good so that's the case how we call a
non-phynical role it's a non-phynical
role so you won't yes and uh to to put a
need in anyone's arm uh I'll follow John
Ambulance do offer that though so
everyone wants to do that they can have
a look there but actually this is a very
straightforward role you don't need any
specialist training uh you'll be guided
on site as to what you need to do when
you arrive and we provide people with
some some background information before
they even get there so you'll you'll
feel completely at ease good so so how
do people get involved then where should
we be sending them to to find out how to
apply and to help out what what they
need to do is to head to the website NHS
volunteeresponders.org.uk and follow the
process there this this is a very
flexible role it you can uh organize
your volunteering on an app so you need
a smartphone to do it but it does make
it incredibly flexible and and that's
been a real Boom for people they can
organize their shifts around the time
they have available
um Fiona forgive me for being slightly
pessimistic but I'm a journalist who's
been covering politics for the past
couple of years just give us an idea of
what might happen if you don't get the
numbers or are you convinced that you're
going to get there
I'm convinced we're going to get there
we've seen nothing but supports since we
started this endeavor I mean we've seen
people come through we have people of
all ages and backgrounds and that's one
of the things they love about it you
know you meet people in your community
you wouldn't otherwise meet and uh you
know your help in your community to
boost their immunity at this really
important time we can't emphasize enough
think how tough this winter is going to
be so helping out with this vaccination
program is a real support to your
community and to the NHS at General hot
Fiona I mean I remember when I went for
my first vaccination the Battersea Art
Center I'm fine with needles I'm fine
with injections but you know a little
bit of a heart started pumping the
volunteers got me through it so look
wishing you all the very best with the
campaign and Fiona long course from
throw voluntary service thanks so much
thank you
and you lock can stay right where you
are at the top of the hour we will be
getting Labor's take on a momentous week
in British politics with what just hours
to go now four of them in fact until the
first head-to-head pmqs between Rishi
sunak and Pierre Starman see after this
[Music]